One of the greatest challenges that women leaders face
is simply accessing the same leadership
opportunities as men.
Women leaders are often presented with lower quality
leadership opportunities
because organizations don't value women's contributions
and capabilities in the same way they do men's.
According to a 2,005 research study,
women are much more likely than men to be recruited
for precarious,
high risk, and extremely challenging leadership roles.
This is known as the glass cliff phenomenon,
and these precarious leadership positions
set women up to fail.
Female leaders are often forced
or compelled to take these riskier roles
because they simply
don't have access to other leadership opportunities.
And even if woman leaders
managed to survive the glass cliff by staying employed
or turning things around,
their performance is usually not rewarded.
Research finds that
regardless of a firm's performance,
and this is a bit of a shocker,
female CEOs
are 45% more likely than male CEOs to be dismissed.
And while male leaders
are much more likely to be retained
when the organisation performance is high,
the same is simply not true for women.